direction ouagadougou la capitale du
burkina faso où s'est ouvert ce matin le
10e sommet de la francophonie en
présence bien sûr du président français
jacques chirac et de la plupart des
présidents de la francophonie et
notamment des présidents africains mais
en l'absence très remarquée du président
de la côte d'ivoire laurent gbagbo on
retrouve sur place véronique sainte
olive et francis forger
un accueil comme jacques chirac les aime
dans les rues de ouagadougou ils sont
des milliers pour chanter et danser en
l'honneur du président de la république
à l'occasion du 10ème sommet de la
france ô folies est en pleine crise de
la côte d'ivoire le président de la
république est venu réclamer le soutien
et la médiation de tous les voisins
africains
56 chefs d'état et de gouvernement de la
famille francophone sont ici à tous
jacques chirac demande de veiller à
l'application de l'embargo sur les armes
en côte d'ivoire il en appelle aussi aux
bonnes relations et aux influences
multiples pour tenter de calmer le jeu
le premier objectif de la francophonie
c'est de favoriser la paix d'emblée
jacques chirac rappelle pourquoi la
france demeure en côte d'ivoire
elle n'est pas là pour imposer sa propre
paix mais pour tenter d'éviter la guerre
civile et le chaos nous devons adresser
à la côte d'ivoire un message ferme et
amicale à la fois pour que les partis
renoncent à la politique du pire et à la
violence à l'illusion de la solution
militaire et renouer avec le dialogue
seul chemin vers la paix
si ce sommet est largement dominé par le
problème de la côte d'ivoire les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement vont remettre
sur le tapis les éternelles questions du
développement économique de la pauvreté
de la faim de l'éducation avec l'espoir
de faire avancer les choses et de ne pas
en rester au voeu pieux